hi i'm heejun and i'm joanie and today
we're gonna be drawing
my neck hurts that's not what we're
drawing today we're going to draw
marvel superheroes from memory
didn't we already do that we did dc i
don't know we did justice league
whatever
your universe is straight whatever
they're all the same guy
this is right up your wheelhouse i hope
so i'm like
please do not mess this one up because
i've read so many
marvel comics well let me tell you i'm
gonna be making up a lot of stuff on
this one
but first uh be sure to stick around to
the end of the video to find out how you
can enter for a chance to win this wacom
intuos tablet courtesy of our good
friends at wacom i'm not wearing shoes
not relevant
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys are drawing spider-man ah
that's the best one he's the best i do
love spider-man
spider-verse is the best movie ever
created
it's really good miles best spider-man
love gwen stefani
love peter parker peter b parker
peter c parker not gwen stefan peter d
parker stacy peter parker
oh okay that's easy okay okay okay i
only can think of his
head thing oh yeah the head thing that
goes up like that yeah
all right let's see don't mess this up
jason don't mess this up what do you
think i'm telling myself
captain marvel oh god captain marvel hip
cool i don't know who this is like
actually so i'm just gonna
i'll try man okay it's like a person
that's all i know
all right i'm gonna try my best to do a
dynamic spider pose
me too oh my god can you give us three
hours
in the comics he was made to be like
short
and muscular oh he's short in the yeah
so which was weird while they
chose hugh jackman to play him because
he's supposed to be like
five feet tall or something like that oh
okay hugh jackman's like what six four
is he oh is he really yeah your
jackman's like really tall if you're
showing any skin
he's very hairy yes i remember that he's
got
the hairiest like arms the shape of
stars are
integrated into the costume i think
there's a star
on the belt buckle it feels like you're
trying to like help me remember but the
thing is i don't know who this is
here um i'm sending you an image of a
lady
a lady with blonde hair okay oh
yeah back in the 90s
spider-man was having a renaissance
with a comic book artist by the name of
todd macfarlane
because he came along and drew
spider-man in a way that no one else had
before
and what different ways can you draw
spiderman he did what was called
spaghetti webs
where spider-man's webs didn't look like
webs they look like strands of spaghetti
like kind of like wrapped around each
other
oh that's what they look like now kind
of yeah so he was kind of a pioneer in
terms
of that he also made the eyes on
the mask bigger than they've ever been
and he also
was the character designer for venom if
your favorite superhero is venom
you're either a really edgy 13 year old
boy or a 25 year old woman that just got
out of a
long relationship another thing in the
90s everyone had
shoulder pads oh okay thank you
i remember that yeah were they pointy
they weren't like pointy they kind of
went up like this like they just kind of
went out and went in like that
okay good i did not draw that i think
for the suit i'm drawing his
arms were sleeveless and then he had the
gloves i appreciate the less clothing
i have to draw the better okay i'm
assuming she has boots yes
i think i think those are correct
assumptions but also i don't know the
character very well so i'm just going to
probably say yes to most of the things
she said yeah i think she has a
cape i don't know oh she's a cape i
don't know i'm sorry marvel fans
who was your favorite spider-man from
spider-verse miles he was
well-written you know he went from like
not really being sure of himself but
then he met gwen stefani
and then he met gwen stefani and she
said whoa
i'm gonna add a bunch of unnecessary
details to this drawing i want to add a
helmet but i'm afraid it's gonna make
her look like
cyclops like that sentence doesn't make
sense to me like i don't have context
for it
like i know i keep saying it just that
it's true you know my favorite
spider-man from spider-verse was peter b
parker do you want to know why
is it because you're old
no it's because he was a nod to the
spider-man
that i grew up with a lot of the jokes
in the beginning when he's like
retelling his story and everything like
that those were all jokes about the
continuity of the spider-man that i grew
up with it's pretty cool
you have no idea what i just said yeah i
was looking at my drawing okay
okay so what is this basic costume it's
really simple sometimes people draw
claw marks on his torso oh okay like
he's
cut himself or like he will cut you i
guess
okay okay yeah his design has kind of
stayed
very similar over the years i'm gonna
give him like the superhero underpants
i know he probably doesn't have it he
doesn't well you know what
it's how i imagine him what i'm slowly
realizing is that it appears that i've
drawn i've drawn one of the hanson
brothers is what i'm really like slowly
realizing
i mean i'm sure there is a crossover i'm
sure of the
of the phantom fandoms he's just yellow
and black right yellow and black or
yellow and blue are yellow and brown
i got it i got this yellow has always
been
a mainstay in his costume like i know
like
maybe vaguely visually what some of them
look like like the avengers may be like
just from seeing posters or something i
just like don't watch any of them
it's actually kind of impressive how is
it impressive how into dark you are but
it's like you have to spend money to go
see them like it means i'm just like
not you know that means you're being
financially responsible yeah
if i just can't think of anything he's
got he's got skin there
i'm taking this hairy body thing and i'm
running with it i'm excited to see what
you're gonna do
i think you'll be surprised oh my god i
just realized i did not draw his other
hand
oh yeah i'm just gonna beef this hand
huh you're gonna beef it
i'm just gonna beef this hand i knew it
i knew that would catch on
you know what he's gonna be like
flicking you off with his claws i'm
perfect
because he's got two you know he's got
three oh two he's got attitude oh dude i
thought he said two i don't think i
know what maybe i'm an innovator i don't
know if anyone's ever flicked
someone off with his claws before well
he does he does the thing where he puts
up just the middle one oh okay
yeah weird i did it the other two are
bending down
at first they didn't want to make
spider-man because they were like oh
nobody likes spiders like this is gonna
be gross that was stanley's story behind
it and he was like
i'll show them i'll make him the most
popular superhero
in the world yeah for some reason he's
been old his whole life
in this scenario he's already like 90.
jason how you doing i'm like struggling
stretch man i'm like struggling to
finish and to like save my reputation
with someone who likes
who likes the comic book i know this is
your round to lose jason
oh my god no pressure but like if i
screwed up a spongebob meme that would
be my devastation
i i actually really like my drawing i
did like i'm pretty proud of it
it's just that like it's probably not
what it the character is at all but like
i like it i like the drawing
and that's what's most important what's
most important is loving yourself
it's true how do you think you did brent
oh man
i think you're gonna be real impressed
uh no i didn't
god awful jason how do you think you did
buddy
this is 100 wolverine how do you feel
about the drawing you did i love it i'm
really proud of it
it's not anything like what you want it
to be though it's a it's an art piece
that i'm going to sell for a million
dollars look for it on etsy
yeah how do you think you did it looks
okay you know it doesn't look
polished doesn't even really look right
but it does look like spider-man how do
you think you did i think i did okay
wow i did my best low-budget
todd mcfarlane style todd mcfarlane
style spider-man spider-man
yeah yeah he would be very upset if he
saw this he said if he saw this
yeah but uh it's definitely spiderman
definitely stop doing that
all right switcheroo switcheroo buckaroo
i was gonna say curse words
[Music]
yes yes here that is amazing
i like yours i like yours too thanks and
you also you also drew
me yeah wow i didn't i i i wasn't that
thoughtful i'm so sorry
well can i draw me in here yeah sure
yeah wow
wow okay yeah okay jason you always
surprise me i feel like it's when you're
the most hard on yourself that you come
at me with these like
really accurate drawings
that looks yeah you got the costume way
more correct than me i
think you know what i think i did but
your pose is
super dynamic and super fun thanks and i
love the speed lines
thank you and you kind of did the
spaghetti style webs yeah
that's i like those yeah they go like
this
oh you did pretty good oh well yours
looks like similar
it's a full body suit actually see i i
knew she had a mask on but
and then her hair comes out of it i like
this character design of this of this
woman
it's very appealing appealing designs i
forgot that she has
two belts like a cool person cool yeah
oh
he's blue in this one i knew he was blue
i should have been
blue okay actually the the head thing
not so off you're i mean you got the
shape yeah sort of the shape
and he's got these like specific claw
marks on his
on his torso yeah it's like some like
little black claws so this is from the
cartoon i should have i shouldn't
remember that
oh and he's got the underwear yeah
i forgot i i i led you astray with that
i know man
i'm sorry i let you i'm feeling better
and better about this
yeah okay so i also screwed up the blue
yeah but you got closer i got closer but
i forgot that he has blue
on his sides his abdomen well like
there's a bunch of spider-man's again
which one are we remembering they're
classic i mean but even the classics
have classics spider-man's been around
for a long time this is true but this is
the original costume is it really yeah
no yeah no yeah you know spiders existed
before spider-man
and spiders aren't red or blue
traditionally
um as far as i know anyway
all right giveaway time if you want to
enter for a chance to win this wacom
intuos s tablet all you have to do is go
to buzzfeed comics on instagram
that's comics on instagram find this
post
and follow the instructions in the
description best of luck if you're post
malone
do not enter this giveaway what why
what do you have against post malone i
don't know post malone can buy his own
[Music]